Desde ontem, o que não ficou claro até o momento.
Para vocês.
Me falem falar que é tudo. Não tá? Por favor.
Mas me falem. O que não está claro.
Isso é importante, porque eu quero começar uma nova perspectiva hoje.
Então queries.
Posso, ser a cobaia, né.
Pode. Claro. Fique à vontade.
O processo para mim todo, ficou claro tá luan o processo para mim ficou, claro assim.
Quando, eu pego e.
Que o jogo, converge, contra uma especificação se ele tem um contexto do meu repositório.
Ele vai fazer, ali vai entender o que eu tenho contra o que ele vai implementar e se eu consigo fazer aquilo.
Por trás ali ele vai dividir em contratos ali swim lanes vai usar o tech pack ali o sim. Wise e isso ficou claro agora o que eu não entendi é assim tipo assim.
É um problema que eu tenho na minha, realidade o cliente não sabe. Especificar bem então ele manda uma, especificação alto nível.
E aí, eu pego. Ali e jogo contra o meu repositório cara eu tenho como cercar, ele mais disso eu tenho que, dar mais insumo para ele, para ele, conseguir, ter mais direção.
Sabe.
Me dá um exemplo.
Por exemplo eu recebo uma, especificação técnica, você vai ter que fazer uma, integração com arquivos externos para qualificar a nossa base única.
Tá.
Essa vai ser a sua fonte você vai ter que pegar da tela tal beleza.
Eh imagine, que eu não tenho nem nada de, projeto internamente no meu repositório, que faça isso mas eu tenho sparques eu tenho.
Beleza.
Pythons eu tenho vários, contextos ali internos.
Ou, converge a proposta dele nesse caso, é entender o que eu tenho e me propor o que eu posso, adequar, ali dentro para fazer ou, eu estou viajando cara não não é isso flávio você, tem que.
Não? Boa pergunta. é isso mesmo. é exatamente mais ou menos por aí.
Tá.
Eu não creio nada que olha mais para o prisma do cliente, por exemplo.
Ficar fazendo. Pergunta para ele até.
Você está satisfeito com o que você vai entregar?
Ainda não.
Mas sim, você está certo. Esse é o caminho.
Beleza obrigado.
E quando não tem um requisito muito bom. Aí a gente começa. O que eu entendi, tá? Ao longo desse Tempo Trabalhando Com Ia.
Cara que nada. Que é isso? Que quando o.
Vocês estão me escutando? Bem.
So. Só um minutinho. Acho que eu tô com algum problema.
Ditou mais, a sua câmera você está congelando lá.
Tá? Só um minuto. Minha internet. Acho que tá ruim.
Deixa eu ver se auto internet está funcionando. Só um minuto.
Como está agora? Tá melhor.
A mesma coisa.
Vocês me escutam?
Ouvir você bem sua imagem.
Se eu desligar o áudio, melhora.
Me durou.
Desligou o vídeo na verdade né. Agora seu áudio está perfeita.
Dada. Perfeito, né? Tá, eu vou desligar o vídeo aqui porque eu tenho três Internet, duas caíram e não estou voltando.
Então eu vou desligar o vídeo aqui.
Sem problemas sem problem.
Para a gente não ter esse problema.
Vamos lá. Deixa eu compartilhar a tela com vocês aqui.
A gente começa.
Pode perguntar. Lucas.
Boa noite.
Boa noite luan eu tenho uma dúvida em relação às vezes.
Por exemplo você tem um projeto para fazer só que você tem muitas alternativas para resolver o problema.
Eu fiquei na, dúvida se você, sempre desse na, menor granularidade e tenta fazer, mvps diferentes ou, onde no processo você, para, para fazer, esse, mvp.
Boa pergunta. Sim.
Para entender qual seria.
Boa pergunta.
more killer bunch.
De voce.
fascio.
No regimentara eu gelia.
EC.
fefaito.
Double saw.
A week potential agua.
urgesava as mias opsois.
Kafka, eu se entao…
E.
desena.
Oy, como que eu faco estraban, ella post.
La vida de um pies nos technologias, la veidade o vono clinti.
Yo pego todas as espostas que preciso para.
Nese proceso.
Sio estresao clinche.
Compreguntas pechenentes.
Esoque estraumente fast.
que.
Esto eso es decis una veridades domain,
O cliente nao tem.
Umaisata?
Ci.
Quito.
You might as well sois. Cave.
para voce.
Active Directory.
Agent se.
Ice.
Obviamente.
T. R.
I'm cleaner song.
It's Desi.
Okay, you see.
Eu vote. Eu vote.
Erica, Ukraine
So, Javotta.
Wayoj, mais bilis.
Entao que haunte seio, voce vai drive, entao eso mejo bastant. Estao conceive un problema de definisao de technologia.
vezes.
Filament this process of ease.
Najo to a se, muito munto meso.
See?
Mas.
pasta.
Entao veg de las tu de busto.
principalmente.
Surge forage mode.
planejana mi opinion.
Signe ponces.
Approach my passion.
You know se un tem se voce estavo oy so se estabo uno canao mais umas tremendo.
a engineer.
And we can now kill Namoru Baston.
Muito.
Euros um muito es.
Yeah, he per example, se voceolia.
Right, you know
Okay, tell me.
Sometime.
It is high resolution
Winfish acheascosis.
Huh.
This is my legend of the no.
Eu toba vendo oy uma presentaccao.
que fe lasada pocus dias.
No SQL free specific account.
Peter weary.
than blocked. How to generate mergeable code with a context engine.
Esi.
follow the duck factory.
Why do Agent Wolf?
Ben. Ta.
International Super contest.
It follows the tech factory.
Ta.
And they show…
Yveso con sigo.
Mei tenas estamiloa.
de legita.
Rega.
Portugal village.
That's all the footage is just plural como umacht soluzonis infomo AI engineer.
Tradocao.
G, Java propaito, na cuatafira.
Dadas.
Your origin reve da hora.
As for factory done.
effus.
Eto, porizo qui aide adoquierao convejo fue essone.
No se horologne de voces.
Borges, ne.
Esa constante masse de entradne, uma que o.
Eto aide voce pegais, e tempo de tare efos equi, da veta de desto.
Y de comparela em que entarrefas.
Que elas entram dentro de uma fábrica.
E elas saem construídas.
é isso. Tá.
Então a incepção inicial foi basicamente.
Desse aglomerado. Aqui tá.
Tá.
Transcript muitas vezes. é um resumo. Vozes na cabeça.
é chat. Slack Slack também é um outro ponto muito bom aqui. Tá.
Eu também recebo muita coisa no Slack.
Então eu botei o. Converge justamente para fazer esse processo. Pô, eu tenho uma kill.
Que está chegando constantemente. Coisas novas, né?
Daí. Eu tenho o meio que é a fábrica Lights out, que é desligada.
Então ele faz o building publica, escreve valida. Então ele vai passando para o que a gente chama de Gates de portões.
Esses portões. Inicialmente.
Eles são feitos e desenhados por você. O loop.
Não a máquina no loop. E aí você vai se tirando desse loop de tempos em tempos. Então vamos supor.
Vou dar um exemplo aqui para vocês.
Recebi um transcript. Pô extraia.
Todas. Você estava na reunião. Você estava na reunião. Extraia todos os pontos importantes da reunião.
Ele extraiu. Você validou? é.
Fez sentido aqui. Duas, três, quatro, cinco. Cara. Extraiu dez vezes. Você olhou e falou: Pô, é realmente tá extraindo corretamente.
Minha esquil tá muito boa para extrair isso aqui.
Você vai criar um portão de validação.
E vai falar, cara, ou você vai criar um Evol que espera algumas coisas.
Ou você vai criar uma Llm para julgar aquilo ou alguma coisa que te dê.
Um portão, porra, eu tenho script. Esse script tem mais tantas linhas como que eu classifico esse script.
Ele descreve as tarefas. Então você pode criar o quê? Um gate, um portão de validação.
E aí você se tira dessa validação.
Aí você vai. Pra próxima, pô, recebi agora eu quero registrar essas atividades. Registra pra mim no gira.
Aí você vai lá criar uma Skill, por exemplo, para registrar no giro.
Ele registra lá, simplifica dez vezes. Fala, é.
Está registrando. Top está marcando a pessoa.
Está assinalando aqui está criando as dependências. Está tudo certo.
Aí. O que você vai fazer? Põe um portão.
Que fala. Olha, toda vez que uma tarefa chegar obrigatoriamente, você vai ter que falar. Qual a relação dela.
Você vai ter que linkar ela com uma outra. Você vai ter que assinalar uma pessoa.
Você vai ter que criar um título dessa forma tal. E aí o Evol ou o Gate valida isso. Agora Eu Saio Desse Portão E Assim Eu Vou Fazendo.
Até a hora que você vai. Desliga a fábrica e a fábrica vai rodar.
Realmente de luz apagada. Então não é tipo essa ideia de porra. Eu cheguei dia dois. Tá tudo apagado. Não, não é. Tá.
E aí uma das coisas importantíssimas.
é a evidência.
Beleza. Eu tenho entrada. Eu tenho alguma coisa no meio. Mas eu tenho que ter uma prova irrefutável de saída.
E senão nunca eu vou conseguir de fato, validar o que é verdade.
A Luan. Sempre a gente vai ter essa prova irrefutável para traduções. Sim, sempre.
Para coisas novas. Não.
Quem vai validar.
Coloca aqui. Quem vocês acham que valida no final? Se você não tem um local de provas.
Tá.
O Lup. Ontem, Ricardo foi, na verdade, ele pegar todas as tarefas. Na verdade, pegar todos os requisitos e criar Todas As Tarefas Lá Na Pasta.
Então ele fez um loop, né? De olhar. Quais são? Sim, Swim, Lanes e Legs. E disso aí ele ir Criando Todas As Atividades.
Então esse foi o loop que a gente fez ontem. Então a gente fez um loop de criar as atividades E Registrar Essa Atividade.
A gente não criou um loop.
De. Na verdade.
Executar as atividades. Esse loop vai entrar hoje, tá.
Então o que? A fábrica não é.
A fábrica não é de fato, um detector de alguma coisa.
Ou um Ci que vai executar alguma coisa.
é algo muito mais complexo. Ela define gates.
Que são validados por humanos.
Ela tem forma de validar.
Ela lê contrato, por exemplo. Então essa é a forma de você entender. Então, o que você tem que.
Sempre planejar na cabeça, tá?
Os componentes principais.
Então esses são os três componentes principais que eu diria. Entrada de tarefas com menor nível possível.
Fábrica de execução.
Com o contexto que você queira dar para ela. Em uma evidência final.
E aí? Isso é uma das coisas que inclusive eu estou viajando daqui a pouco para poder explicar para o cliente.
é que a gente, no começo do projeto.
A gente estava mais ou menos aqui. Nível.
Dois para três, por exemplo, que é o que a maioria da galera está.
Então, se você olha um pouquinho dos níveis de o quão autônomo o seus sistemas são. Então aqui é um Pouquinho Da Ideia De Sistemas Autônomos Tá De Níveis.
Então você tem o que? Primeiro a gente chama de Spice alto complete que eu acredito que ninguém.
Está nesse nível hoje. De trabalhar com alto complete, ficar dando Tab, ver pedaços de boilerplate de code sendo feito. Eu Acredito Que Isso Já Acabou.
A gente tem gente que tem ali.
Deixando ai, escrevendo pedaços do processo. Documentação boilerplate, esse tipo de coisa.
Eu também acredito que poucas pessoas estão aqui.
Eu vejo muita gente no L dois, que é o nível que você já está um pouquinho do autopiloto, mas Para Algumas Coisas Tá.
Você tem um agente fazendo coisas determinadas ali. Você não tem um contexto muito bem definido.
é.
Você não tem.
Um sistema ainda definido. Muito bem. Você está ali. Meio que ainda no processo de Vibe Code um, diria.
Aqui no L Ii são que as coisas começam a ficar um pouquinho mais sérias. Tá.
No l tres. Você já tem esse conceito de autônomo. Então, basicamente, você está olhando a perspectiva muito mais de.
Deixar o agente executar. E está muito mais na parte de revisar o que ele fez.
Você está literalmente agora, passando setenta do tempo.
Revisando o código que é escrito pelo agente. E está tudo certo.
Depois disso, a gente vai mais para a ideia do Pm.
The product manager. Então agora não só.
Eu não. Também faço a validação de código.
Eu valido que o resultado.
Evaluate Outcome Instead of Reading Code. Isso é maravilhoso.
Como que se alcança isso.
Dot.
Como que eu sei quando eu estou no L quatro, quando você tem voz para validar sua tarefa.
Eu não estou olhando o código. Como ele foi escrito. Eu estou.
Verificando o resultado desse código. E como que ele está.
é isso? Basicamente tá.
E quando você olha para Dark Factory.
Você basicamente não tem nada disso.
Porque tudo isso já foi.
Validado. Beforehand.
Então, na verdade, você está controlando só o loop. Você está basicamente só de vez em tempos. Em tempos verificando O Que Está Acontecendo.
Você vai escrever o Spec ou o processo.
E você vai ver essa fábrica performar. E aqui você vai desenvolver uma coisa chamada muito fortemente.
Chamada de Taste, que é o gosto.
E aí? Olha só. Que interessante isso, né.
O texto. Ele vem mesmo com o tempo.
Quanto mais você vai passando entre esses níveis aqui, mais gosto você vai desenvolvendo.
Então é inevitável que você comece a literalmente ter o taste. O gosto.
é eu cair de novo.
Eu posso reiniciar o computador, mas vai demorar uns cinco minutos. Vocês querem que eu faça.
Tá? Eu já volto. Então. Então deixa eu reputar aqui, rapidinho.
Beleza. Voltei agora a gente, né.
Espero que a gente esteja, que a gente tenha nenhum problema mais.
Vocês me escutam bem, né?
Escutam, beleza? Valeu.
Vamos ver se a minha câmera me obedece aqui por algum moto.
Olha que milagre!
E aí uma coisa importante da gente entender é que a fábrica, como eu já tinha dito anteriormente.
Ela não é um switch que você simplesmente troca. Ela é um dial. Então é exatamente o que eu acabei de falar.
Você vai na verdade ajustando ela.
Isso é uma coisa legal, porque às vezes o cliente tem essa concepção de que.
Ou você é ou você não é? Você vai aumentando o nível. Você vai elevando o nível de acordo com O Que Você Vai.
E aí isso é ganhado. Ganho com evidência.
Então a forma de você elevar o nível da sua fábrica, ou do que você faz.
é no nível de evidência você achar as evidências que corroboram isso.
Dito isso.
Ainda tem uma coisa. Quando você olha para um repositório ou por um processo que você tem.
O que você quer também entender é o seguinte.
Que muito disso que eu estou falando.
às vezes você tem um repositório, e isso não quer dizer que seu repositório inteiro é um Dark Factory, não.
Isso quer dizer que um pedaço do seu repositório é um Dark Factory, talvez, né? E.
O resto, não é? E tá tudo certo. Então, dentro do seu repositório, você pode ter níveis ali. De onde você está.
Beleza. Então, o que converge se a gente for olhar, realmente faz fim a fim.
Então, se a gente for olhar o converge, ele cria essa fábrica contínua.
Então muita gente me perguntou: porra.
O que você.
Parou de usar o Agents Spec Qsdd.
E começou a utilizar o Converge, que é um Idd, um Intent Driven Development.
Porque é exatamente isso aqui que eu pedi para ir a colocar pra mim aqui.
A gente tem três fases muito marcantes aqui. Na verdade, quatro fases marcantes aqui.
A primeira fase marcante são as fases relacionadas ao que o humano deve fazer.
O que ele deve interagir.
Então pô, eu vou capturar várias informações.
Eu vou compilar a intenção do que ele quer.
Ele vai de fato extrair as estruturas de ida. As Architecture Decision Records.
Ele vai decompor as atividades depois que ele decompõe.
A gente tem uma parte de falar. Pô beleza. Olha.
Essas atividades foram decompostas aqui. Agora vamos chegar a um consenso.
O consenso é o seguinte: você entendeu isso? Ah, entendi. Vai ser assim assim assado? Sim, dessa forma é assim.
Mas e assim? Como vai funcionar? Vai funcionar assim? Assim? Assim.
Então a Ia vai te perguntar várias perguntas durante essa parte do consenso, é que quando a gente foi utilizando O Converge Eu, Fui Cortando Vários Pedaços Para A Gente Conseguir Entregar O Conteúdo Todo.
Mas você que tem acesso ao converge. Agora vai conseguir falar, cara, quero ir no converge todas as linhas.
Você vai ver que aqui em todos eles eu tenho vários Grims. Eu tenho vários processos, mas aqui é bem chato.
Aqui nessa parte quatro, você tem um griummy que ele ia falar. Tá.
A gente precisa chegar a um entendimento mútuo, então preciso saber se você sabe.
O que você está pedindo. E ele vai te lançar várias perguntas. E você vai responder.
Você pode responder uma por uma. Você pode responder via áudio? Você pode responder via Bet? Enfim.
A maior que ele. Está satisfeito com isso.
Falo. Pô a partir daqui. Agora é comigo.
Ele passa para o Task Spec. O Task Spec não precisa da gente mais só para dar o Stamping, mas Aí Quem Vai Dar.
O Stamping não vai ser mais. Você vai ser a fábrica, né? Porque a gente já chegou no acordo.
Daí. Eu registro essas informações no mesh ou no linear, ou dentro do repositório que a gente viu.
Depois a gente faz o binding, que é pegar todas essas tarefas e assinalar para dentro do Harness e falar, pô beleza.
Vai executar a via Converge.
A gente tem quase os executores aqui pô Codecs Cloud e Kimi, por exemplo.
E a gente vai fechar as tarefas.
Quais são os tamanhos dela? Quais são as características que elas podem fazer?
E assim por diante. E a gente começa. O quê? A passar essa informação dentro do looping?
E aí o looping? Ele tá o quê? Utiliza apagada.
Então imagina agora que toda a requisição.
Você concorda comigo que uma vez que você faz isso.
Muitas das vezes. Você não precisa passar.
Novamente. Então o que eu estou querendo dizer.
Pô. Quando eu recebo. Ninguém perguntou isso durante o treinamento, eu pensei que vocês iam perguntar. Ou pelo menos vocês Perguntarem E Eu Não Vi.
Que é o seguinte: poxa.
Toda vez que eu tiver uma nova tarefa.
Para aquele processo, por exemplo.
Eu preciso passar pelos nove passos.
Então.
Então o que eu quero perguntar aqui para meu.
Para o meu Second de Brain, né?
Toda vez que eu recebo o requisito de uma fábrica que já existe.
Se eu tenho que toda vez ficar passando.
Por toda ela constantemente. Todos os passos.
Vamos ver.
E aí é aquela coisa, né.
Como produto. Foi eu que criei. Eu sei fazer as perguntas. Então a Ia é dessa mesma sacada.
Se eu nunca fizesse essa pergunta, eu estaria repetindo todos os passos todas as vezes, tá.
Então deixa eu ver se ele pegou aqui.
Ele não pegou.
Tá vendo? Se você não sabe que você está perguntando.
Como que você sabe que a resposta é muito bom. Isso aqui, cara.
Como se sabe que a resposta verdadeira se você não sabe o que você está perguntando.
Será que você está validando esse cara.
ó de novo. Ele não pegou.
Ele não pegou de novo.
Eu vou ter que ser mais específico. Eu tenho que falar.
Na cara dele o que eu quero? Porque ele ainda não entendeu o que eu pedi para ele.
Eu pedi para ele justamente esse crime.
Dentro do converge.
Eu tenho uma coisa chamada Gelane Rowdy.
A gente tem três tipos de vias.
Eu tenho a via fest. Eu tenho a via normal e eu tenho a via full. Olha que legal, né?
Então, como ninguém perguntou, ele já é preparado para isso.
Então essas lenes, eles mostram.
Aqui, ó aí! Ele pegou agora. Beleza. Cvg Lane.
Mas ele ainda não explicou. Caraca, velho.
Deixa eu mostrar uma coisa para vocês.
Agora eu fiquei puto.
Vou mostrar uma coisa pra vocês.
Eu estou tentando amar o Google, mas ele realmente não está me ajudando.
Não é mencionada.
Tá beleza. Então, dizendo, ele não é mencionado.
Vamos ver. Então você é mencionado ou não é? Mas enfim, a gente volta aqui. Já. Já.
Então a gente vai passar por esse processo aqui.
E isso tudo é um loop.
Então, se você olhar, eu estou entendendo a intenção.
Eu estou contextualizando o que é contextualizar.
Os Ad são formas de contextualização. Então, se a gente vier aqui dentro de Docs.
Adrs. Eu tenho contextualização. Isso é contextualização.
Entendeu? Então eu tô.
Descobrindo a intenção.
Dando contextualização.
Citando Harness, que é fazendo um binding do ambiente.
Fazendo loop decompondo e fazendo loop.
E aplicando em volta.
E isso vai gerar um resultado para mim.
Então, basicamente isso. Simples intenção, contexto.
Harness Loop e vol.
Então o que a gente viu, né?
Desde a segunda até a quinta.
A gente trabalhou muito no processo fim, a fim da camada que é legada até a camada que é moderna.
Só que a gente não de fato, viu toda a execução acontecer. Até o momento.
E eu deixei tudo isso no final, justamente pra gente conseguir saber.
O que vai acontecer. Além disso.
Tem um novo tipo de arquivo que vai chegar, que chegou para a gente que foi anunciado ontem.
Tu precisa ser refaturado. Na verdade, precisa ser criado dentro da fábrica. Então a gente vai olhar. Isso.
Tá.
Outro ponto importante. Tá.
A gente tem três linhas aqui muito importantes.
Que é? Lembra que a Fonte pode mentir?
Então o que a fonte pode mentir?
Pode acontecer de chegar.
Um problema. De onde você tem cento e quarenta e três, setenta e sete, mas na verdade, chegou o arquivo Cento E Setenta E Três Quarenta E Cinco.
Então esse valor na hora que você vai ver, o detalhe está errado.
Então, muitas das vezes, a fonte pode vir com um problema.
E a gente vai descobrir isso dentro do arquivo. O arquivo vai vir com o cálculo errado.
Uma. Outro ponto é quando a gente vê o Halphiven, né?
Que é. Puxa, eu sei que no legado tá certo.
Mas, na verdade, o moderno está errado.
Então a gente precisa ter uma forma de falar. Se a forma moderna que a gente fez está errada.
E por último, quando a gente for bater.
O moderno com o legado. Se a gente quiser comparar.
A gente pode ter um problema também deles não estarem batendo.
Então o que eu quero que vocês entendam aqui, desses três pontos.
Sempre tentar achar o denominador comum.
Que é a verdade.
Tá, então.
A verdade é o seguinte.
Nem ele achou aqui. Deixa eu ver aqui.
Então esses três.
Então, o que a gente vai ver hoje, né? A gente vai recapitular o que a gente fez.
De fim a fim, a gente vai ver esse registro no Línea.
A gente vai trabalhar. Os tipos. Dois, três, quatro e cinco.
A gente vai testar um Smoke test. O que é, Smoke? Test fim a fim. Todos os tipos.
Do um ao cinco. A gente vai trazer um novo tipo para Engines.
E a gente vai criar. O quê? Um flywheel de lições.
O que é um Fly Wheel de lições.
é exatamente isso aqui.
Mas no final, quando ele acaba, o evol.
Ou quando ele está no loop. Se ele identificar um problema, o que ele vai fazer? Ele vai aprender com esse problema.
Ele vai tentar literalmente aprender com isso.
Então, quando os centavos não batem no nosso sistema.
Quais são os problemas que eu tenho? O que acontece de fato.
Lembra que a gente não pode excluir esse valor. A gente tem que simplesmente validar. Ele.
E guardar essa informação. E a ideia é que, se eu achar um problema durante esse processo, a ideia é Que Eu Tenha O Quê.
We'll fly lições para criar um skill. Então, na prática.
Eu tentei embedar tudo isso no Harness.
E deu muito ruim pra mim, tá?
Porque quando os modelos evoluíram.
Eu precisei. O meu Harness é muito Fit. Ainda.
Muito grosso.
Por exemplo, na Curve. Eu tenho sábado e domingo para refaturar a parada todinha para entregar.
Então assim laile, né.
Tem o Hardness? é muito grosso.
Então eu tenho muito, tipo assim. ó.
Quando fazer isso. Quando acontecer, isso faz isso.
Quando você passar por essa opção, você vai nesse documento e vê isso aqui. Então eu tenho muita regra.
Que faz Llm: hoje.
Ser pior do que antes. Antigamente. Você precisava dar instruções mais caras hoje. Você pode dar somente.
A ideia. A intenção inicial é deixar ele.
Fazer isso. Ele vai fazer isso muito melhor.
Então eu preciso reduzir.
Né? Para ter o quê?
Balde Grosso.
Mais um Harness fino, tá? E aí a ideia de você fazer um Harness fino é que agora você consegue Utilizar Qualquer Indian Para Fazer Isso.
Então a gente vai começar a fazer isso.
A gente viu duas coisas importantes aqui, tá? A primeira parte é o que a gente chama, né?
Do literalmente do balde do Rails, né?
Que é como que a gente garante.
Que as coisas não vão ser modificadas. Aqui. A gente falou do binding.
A gente falou na terça e na quarta.
Sobre criar as novas linhas, mas a gente não trabalhou nele.
A gente falou do Goldenmat Pi.
Que é um documento que a gente vai validar. Se esses números batem realmente, tá.
E do outro lado, a gente teve. O quê? O Task Spec.
O Cvg, que é o converge.
E toda parte de execução acontecendo. E criando as atividades. Para mim.
Então agora a gente vai começar literalmente a trabalhar com elas.
O que a gente tem. O que a gente deixou na quinta ontem, né?
Então a gente tem presente aqui as evidências.
Dos testes iniciais que a gente fez.
A gente tem a quebra da Swim Lennes. E a gente tem várias tarefas lá.
Dentro do ambiente, assim como.
O teste desse arquivo em Park.
Então a gente tem essa informação lá. Então, se a gente vier aqui, por exemplo.
A gente tem toda a parte de tarefas de evidência.
E a gente tem toda a parte.
Do Pipeline como um todo.
Tá que a gente vai rodar aqui?
It is que está dentro do moderno. Então, se eu abrir aqui o moderno.
Eu tenho uma camada Landing na camada Landing, eu tenho os meus parques. Lembra que a gente viu isso no parque.
Que a gente deu ele. Então ele está aqui.
Tudo que aconteceu ontem.
Ah, agora ele achou. Tá vendo?
Olá.
Pois eu explico para vocês aqui.
A gente olhou bastante para um tipo, né?
Que era o que a gente falou a semana toda do Card settlement. Agora a gente vai ver. Na verdade, Como Ele Vai Se Comportar Com Os Outros Quatro.
Uma coisa legal aqui é que todos eles possuem uma forma diferente. é isso que eu acho muito interessante. Da fábrica.
Porque a fábrica é um processo.
No final das contas, meio que deterministas.
Mas qual a grande sacada que ele não vai fazer? Só uma coisa igual, sempre ele pode se adaptar a Vários Tipos Diferentes De Arquivos.
Então, nesse caso, aqui, como a gente pode ver.
A gente tem um arquivo que é Iso.
Aqui. Eu tenho um Tf aqui. Eu tenho.
Exatos de duzentos e quarenta bytes aqui. Eu tenho um dado que tem especificação um pouco diferente.
Aqui. Eu tenho por colunas.
Tá vendo? Então, assim cada arquivo tem uma forma diferente aqui no processo.
Então vamos dar uma olhada lá no nosso repositório.
Então vamos aqui em nove pay. Quem quiser seguir. Vamos, Run.
But no último dia.
E vamos abrir aqui. Pré Flight.
Para flight. é só verificar se a gente tem essas informações. Aqui. Todos os arquivos estão que a gente tem.
Agora vamos fazer um recap.
Do tipo um descer lá no recap. Tipo um.
Deixa eu abrir aqui.
Desde o que hoje eu estou usando o cloud.
Por quê? Porque hoje eu voltei a me apaixonar por ele de novo. Hoje eu estou fazendo as pazes com Ele Hoje Ele Se Comportou Muito Bem.
Hoje. Ele não fez mais. Eu não sei se vocês têm isso na assinatura de vocês.
Mas na minha assinatura, acontece umas coisas assim, tipo.
Grotesque total que é tipo assim.
Leia esse documento para mim.
E faça tal coisa e tal coisa. Eu juro, não estou mentindo. Então é uma assinatura de vinte x.
Aí, beleza. Aí eu boto pra ele ler. Ele gasta um pouquinho de tempo.
I role minha assinatura trinta e cinco gasta. Falei, caralho. Eu pedi para ele ler a porra de um documento.
E daí? Eu peço para ele. Ah, creio. Escreva um novo slide.
A cabo.
Eu sei. Então, assim.
Dar umas paradas. Parece que ele está muito doidão. Sabe.
às vezes eu acho que é só eu, mas acho que tem uma galera reclamando disso também.
Ele está assim. Uma coisa. A assinatura está muito estranha.
Mas vamos ver aqui. ó.
O que a gente perguntou, né? Para entender.
O fim, a fim.
Dalene moderna. Olha só. Que legal!
Vamos ler toda lei no moderno, né?
Além moderna, gerou uma evidência.
De cento e setenta e tres. Quarenta e cinco, né?
Na verdade, o moderno não desculpa a evidência normal do antigo.
Gerou a reconciliação de cento e setenta e três, quarenta e cinco.
Quando a gente rodou o cenário lá no primeiro dia.
Quando a gente rodou esse Steel Thread, que é o mínimo. Ele gerou essas informações. Olha só. Que foda essa investigação.
No Landing que a gente desenhou.
Ele pegou e gravou Modern Landing.
Botou aqui essa informação.
Ele escreveu um documento. Parquê.
Um outro vai lidando.
Porque se alguém tentar fazer mais alguma coisa, tentar fazer o chá.
Vai dar problema. Ele jogou um Jason aqui, então eu tenho um documento do parquê que foi escrito.
Esse documento foi depois colocado dentro da onde? Do Lake House.
Então ele foi num Bet com o nome dele.
Courtesy. E o valor e o Apply de value dele foi de cento e setenta e tres, quarenta e cinco.
As duas questões aqui funcionaram. Então, o moderno vezes o contrato.
Deu bom. E o legado desses? O contrato deu bom.
E os dois deram. Bom, então a gente fez a tradução. Os nossos agentes fizeram a tradução.
E a gente chegou no mesmo resultado. E quem provou isso?
A banca, né? Ou reconciliation.
Que é o nosso contrato.
Então isso quer dizer pela prova.
Que o valor exatamente funciona.
Então, para isso, a gente tem que abrir esse cartão aqui.
Quem já executou isso aqui em casa. E quem tiver.
Um parquê.
Pode abrir.
Could Be. Só peço para ele fazer aqui. Integram.
E aí?
Dentro da atividade. Qual foi a atividade que foi feita? Foi essa atividade.
Ter, tipo um landim passe.
A gente tentou executar ela uma vez.
Oival dela deu zero. Ou seja, deu tudo certo.
Ela foi aceita.
Só que na época, naquele momento.
A gente não tinha o Bagster ainda funcionando. O sistema de orquestração. Olhando tudo isso.
Porque a gente só fez a tradução.
Do processo de engenharia de software.
E ele foi aprovado por mim.
Tá.
Depois a gente também teve o que a gente chama do Source Lie. Uma outra validação que mostra que houve um problema. Ok.
A só se declarou cento e setenta e três, quarenta e quatro e o moderno fez cento e setenta e Três Quarenta E Cinco.
Então a declaração da fonte foi mantida como cento e setenta e três, quarenta e quatro.
O moderno. Sim, Park estava certo, mas a gente teve um problema de validação.
Aí. Ele leu aqui o Duke the Beat.
Achou as informações e entendeu que tudo isso que a gente construiu está batendo com o sistema lá.
Então, até aí, tudo certo.
It is. Não temos nenhum problema.
Conseguimos fazer a validação e provar que esse valor bate no final.
Então a gente olhou esses caras aqui.
Então todas as confirmações realmente.
Então, os dados estão na Land.
A gente tem as evidências.
A gente tem aqui. Na verdade, a.
Fonte que mentiu foi mantida. A gente não excluiu. Não fez nenhuma alteração em cima dele.
Agora a gente vai olhar a parte da segunda parte.
A segunda parte daqui.
A gente vai registrar.
Todas as atividades no Board.
Então.
Quando a gente chegar aqui e passar esse Prompt.
O que eu estou falando? Mal.
Registrar tudo o que aconteceu na quinta do Line Aboard.
Então ele vai basicamente entrar aqui nas tasks. Toques.
Testes. Ele vai registrar.
Todas as atividades do Board.
Então vamos ver se ele vai conseguir fazer isso.
Isso. Ele vai usar a Skill do Converge por detrás dos panos para fazer isso. Obviamente que você tem que ter o linear.
Então aqui, ó ele vai.
Literalmente tentar criar esse board e executar. Ele.
Vê se ele vai fazer, né.
Nolinear Tools Reachable.
Então agora a gente vai ter que fazer. A gente vai ter que.
Configurar o linear pela primeira vez.
Que vai ser? Vmcp.
Ele está falando aqui? Que.
Eu tenho no documento o linear.
Então está aqui em Docs.
Linha board. Quais são as tarefas que têm que ser.
Registradas. A gente precisa.
Então isso vai acontecer uma vez que você vai.
Fazer, que é configurar o Liner no seu projeto.
E aí eu vou trazer uma coisa para vocês que vocês vão falar assim, caralho! Luan, eu amo você. Que vocês querem falar.
Agora ou só depois que eu mostrar lá ele.
Eu estou testando. Isso aqui não está nesse projeto. Mas eu já testei lá na Curv. Tá? E tal.
Te amo. Também.
Testem isso aqui.
O que ele faz, tá? Ele é um gateway.
De permissão e conexão via Mcp.
Ele vem pelo combinator. Então tudo que vem pelo combinator. Você pode prestar atenção.
Então, escrever ferramentas é muito espalhado. Então, o que acontece hoje.
Você vai lá no repositório. Você configura no outro também. Assim por diante.
Então, sem o executo, você tem que simplesmente falar.
Com Ezequiel Tour. Basicamente, o que você tem só para vocês entenderem.
Vocês têm um local.
Então você vai pegar ali Cloud cursor e tal. Você vai fazer todas as configurações, cara, isso é muito foda Vocês Não Sei Se Vocês Entenderam Vocês Entenderam Falam Foda Aí.
Vocês vão conectar esse cara em todos os seus Mcps.
E daí? Você agora só disponibiliza isso para o Cláudio. Então ele vê que automaticamente fala, Ah, pô beleza. Tem o Liner ali.
Ah, pô, beleza. Tem um cursor aqui, ó, e aí você conecta todos os seus.
Caras aqui dentro.
Pegaram.
é um Mcp de Mcps.
Porque senão vai acontecer isso aí que eu estou mostrando para vocês. Tá vendo.
Desculpa essa. Ah, pô no projeto. Eu configurei o Slack no outro. Não.
Pô aqui. Eu configurei o Liner nesse outro. Não aqui. Você vem dentro do executor.
E você coloca tudo dentro. Aí você pode fazer ele.
Você pode colocar ele local? Porque ele open source.
Você pode fazer? Ele via cli.
Então, cara, isso aqui é a parada que mais facilitou a minha vida.
Ultimamente, tá? Eu ainda tô testando.
Mas ele vai fazer o proxy de tudo para vocês. Então, seus agentes.
Mcp no executo. E aí ele vai.
Achando que ele vai fazer então, Ah, pô. Quero ler o li, né? Ele bate no executor aqui e fala. Pô A Gente, Tem Learner Conectado Tem Esse Aqui Então Tá Passa Pra Mim.
Tá.
Exatamente.
Title.
O compose.
Funciona mais ou menos assim, né?
Também. Mas o composo. Você não Deployia ele, tipo local ou tal.
Ele está na web, né? Então aqui você consegue ter o controle.
Mais estrito, um pouquinho diferente. Eu também uso muito compos. O composo. O composo é.
Maravilhoso. Então ele funciona também? Mais ou menos assim. Ele é bem mais robusto, porque ele atende outros casos de uso.
Esse cara aqui. Ele atende esse caso de uso da dor. Do que eu falei pra vocês.
De por vários projetos, configura, faz assim por diante, tá.
Então vamos ver aqui se a gente configura.
O parque. Vamos ver se a gente conseguiu ver o parquê.
A gente conseguiu fazer um bocado aqui. ó.
Bruce Stahlder, Tb.
Vamos ver se a gente tem um direct to be aqui.
Mas eu tenho que estar no lugar certo, né.
Não. Aí não dá.
Ai! O parque!
Ah, muito bom. Ah, tá aqui.
They're Landing Landing. Vamos ver se ele pega aqui. Agora.
Agora.
Oh, query.
Como faz para não virar bagunça entre os projetos.
é justamente adicionando o executor. Pelo menos hoje é o que eu tenho hoje. Um samba do crioulo louco hoje.
Porque aí você tem dentro. Aqui, geralmente você cria um Mcp. Jason, aqui.
Que te aponta por vários lugares.
Geralmente você tem que ficar gerenciando esse tipo de cara para saber onde está, o que faz, assim por diante.
Não, cara. Quero que você configure.
Tá? Vamos vir aqui.
Terminal. Cloud.
Use Mcp. Beleza, ele já achou.
Bairro Mcg.
Cadê você?
Líbia.
Beleza. Teoricamente, conectei.
Enquanto isso, o dado aqui está vendo? Olha que legal!
Um bom soldado.
E aí dá pra gente.
Aqui.
Vamos ler esse cara aqui.
é o mesmo. Então o dado está aqui. Realmente está lá dentro do parque processado.
ótimo. Agora a gente vai registrar.
Essas atividades no linear.
Se ele é inteligente o bastante para entender.
Que ele vai registrar no time, correto, né? Porque dentro do linear você tem times teams têm projetos.
Quer verificar qual que ele vai escolher, se ele vai escolher o Time Luan ou se ele vai escolher, o Time Converge A Ideia é Que Ele.
Escolha.
Se ele for bem inteligente, que ele escolha.
Converge.
Opa, que burro.
Aqui. ó, ele está criando as atividades. Ele só não colocou isso dentro de um projeto.
Que eu não pedi. Mas aqui ele está registrando as atividades. Tá vendo?
Aí, por exemplo, dentro do converge nas Cieli, tem todo o processo que ele guia.
Dessa instalação. Então você usa o Cvg.
E aqui. ó.
Para quando vocês forem explorarem.
Cvg. E aqui você tem setup.
Track Ripo.
Para você, Linkar. Você tem que acertar. Que linha? Kit Hub, gira aí.
Você seta setup que Miller, por exemplo.
Cvg.
Priv.
Aí. Esse cara.
Eu estou com a versão desatualizada do Converge aqui que ele abre aqui. Ele abre.
E você habilita. Ou você pode pedir para ele fazer isso para você, né?
Como eu pedi aqui.
Ele registrou. As atividades estão todas aqui. Não colocou dentro de um projeto. Deixa eu colocar ele.
Você. Vou usar aqui a mesma ideia.
O C. Norfield. Pay.
Se você quiser fazer isso uma vez só, tá?
Agora a gente.
Executar essas atividades.
Desk Spec vai passar todas elas, né?
Então, só para ver se a gente no final, a gente vai.
Terminado com Sims.
Os. Sim, estão aqui. ó.
Docs.
Opa Sins. Então a gente tem o Cinns aqui, que foram divididos.
Temos as atividades, e a gente está organizando as atividades aqui. Ah, que legal.
Aqui, ó exatamente ele usando.
Olha que legal ele usando.
A Skill aqui para registrar tudo.
Agora ele fez, certo? Ele botou até um. Febre. Que legal. Dark Factory.
Você no filme de Pay.
Off Wind repositório Golden Match. Enfim.
E aí ele está registrando as atividades aqui. Tá vendo? Que legal.
Top. Isso aqui, né? ó.
Ele já falou que além de impasse, foi concluída, né? Porque ela foi realmente.
Então está aqui o projeto.
Com as issos registradas.
Beleza.
Agora a gente vai trabalhar na execução deles.
Vamos até essas tarefas.
Como que ele faz, tá? Ele vem aqui. Puxa essa atividade. Porque o que acontece.
O líder é um espelho do repositório.
Então ele sempre vai aparecer aqui.
Tá sempre. Então, se você vier aqui em Docs.
Desks access sempre terão aqui. Elas estarão em diferentes folders.
é que eu fui? Usando pedaços do Converge, tá? Ele vai estar em Folders diferentes.
Deixa eu ver se eu mostro.
Assim, Archive parque e de assim por diante. Depois de um tempo, eu deleto elas.
Mas a ideia é que você vai ter isso aqui, tá? E daí? Ele vai começar a trabalhar, fazer o Cranking Dessas Atividades A Gente Vai Ver.
Já. Já a gente vai executar agora do dois ao cinco.
A gente vai executar todas as tarefas que estavam faltantes.
Opa ponta.
Depois dessas tarefas faltantes, a gente vai executar o Smoke Test.
Tá? O que o Smoke test é é pegar.
Pegar o tipo um e executar ele inteiro e confirmar que ele está em todos os lugares.
Ele passou por toda parte de Landing.
Pousou na camada, fez a validação.
Viu o processo e a gente vai ver.
O degster, né.
Para poder visualizar esse cara.
Então, ansioso para isso aqui.
Então, daqui a pouco, a gente vai começar a ver.
é para a gente ver.
Deixa eu ver o que ele fez aqui.
Tem que stampar Key as the Two That's no lugar certo.
Deixa eu ver uma coisa aqui no Modern.
Tô vendo. é esse aqui que eu quero mostrar. Até o momento.
O moderno só tem o Handler, o modelo pássaro Writer, esquema e Writer do tipo um.
Que a gente só fez o tipo.
Vou ver se a marcha começa.
Dúvidas. Pessoal.
Minha voz está ótima, né? Parecendo.
Pelo menos não está doendo tanto a garganta.
Olha que legal. Isso. Eu quero que vocês entendam.
Olha o Card. Que lindo que ele botou.
Olha a atividade que ele botou. ó.
Aprovado os tipos.
Quais foram? Ele escreveu lá no Board.
On track. Então, quando eu venho aqui, eu acho isso. Massa velho.
Três minutos atrás. Eu venho aqui. Seis completado com dezasseis issos. Eu clico.
Consigo ver o que é on track com a atividade que ele acabou de escrever.
As activities que você vai postando aqui as atividades.
E aí, daqui a pouco, a gente começa a ver.
A movimentação. Ele salvou status.
Aí. ó sério, vocês não acham isso, foda? Não.
Desculpa. Eu acho isso muito.
Magia negra velho na minha.
Humilde opinião.
Então vocês vão ver aqui a parada Bovedo.
A tarefa, rolando.
é vocês não are.
Dark Factory funcionando.
Escrevendo.
Aí de boa. Agora eu só vou pegar um voo. Uma e meia da manhã, chegar oito horas da noite. Mas Tá De Boa.
Um voo? Não, né? Três.
O fim do mundo, bicho.
única coisa foda é deixar a pictucha e a esposa. é difícil.
A garganta.
O preço de como tomar.
Vai tomando.
Estava? Que ele falou que.
Aí. Agora a gente vai falar explicitamente para ele.
Para o convergia.
Legal. Esse aqui, ó converge.
A gente vai falar para ele. O quê?
E isso converge. Task loop.
To execute. Every single.
Every Single. Task.
Before Moving to.
Moving to the next.
Thanks.
Old Tags, Zero One, Two Zero, Five.
Asburg, Tasks.
I aqui. ó, deixa eu ver se ele vai aprovar o plano. Só um minutinho.
Ele fez a primeira, né?
Enquanto ele executa aqui. Eu quero mostrar para vocês.
Converge. Lane.
Deixa só ele aprovar. Aqui.
Lobimos e que o passo a passo não funciona de maneira resumida. A dúvida. Agora está em um caso em Que Eu Importo O Defecto De Um Projeto Em Andamento.
Qual o primeiro passo que eu preciso fazer? Escrever alguma Spec aí, como ele. Starta, a fábrica.
Uma forma mais simples de você fazer isso. Luiz.
Estalo converge no repositório.
Tá.
E aí você pergunta para ele exatamente isso.
Com o converge instalado.
Como que eu faço para iniciar.
Porque o que ele vai fazer? Ele vai começar a olhar.
Os lenes, que é o que eu vou explicar aqui. Agora.
Esses lenes vão te dar uma visão. Muito bem. Do que você vai precisar executar. Ele vai te falar. Isso.
Beleza. Ele já tem essa Skill.
ó, deixa eu ver se ele vai aprovar aqui.
Tá.
é porque o Task Spec Tres oito. Eu não fiz o teste com três nove. Então ele quebrou.
Por isso que ele não executou. Tá?
Ele está com incompatibilidade.
Porque antigamente, só para vocês entenderem o que aconteceu antigamente. O Task Spec, o Simwise e o converge.
O converge. Tinha todas as Engines dentro.
Então agora ele não tem as Indians. Eu quebrei elas.
Agora começar a trabalhar. Aqui é vinte e nove.
O Converge ainda está disponível para vocês baixarem lá. Deixa eu botar aqui.
Weep.
Agora ele tá.
Ele vai corrigir tudo aqui dentro. Você veja.
Desks aí. ó.
Donny Package. Ele vai mover para cá. E agora ele vai conseguir fazer.
Beleza. O que eu converge, Lane? Tá só pra vocês entenderem.
Síntese. Cvg, Lane.
é um acidente de descrever o trabalho em questões e tal, tal tal tal.
Existem três lenes que eu criei aqui. Tá.
A primeira Lane.
Por exemplo, corrige o problema do ritmo.
Tá? Vamos supor.
Ele vai escolher a Lane Fest.
Então ele já vai direto. Já vai criar a tarefa.
Já vai fazer o binding e já vai executar.
é pequeno, reversível.
é rápida.
Aí você vê Gelene normal, Ed, a real Friend Point.
Com a intenção que você quer.
A estrutura que você define. Aí. Ele já vai para o tasking.
Já faz o Baide e já faz o loop.
Então muitos dos processos novos que você aborda, ele já vai ser assim. Então, se você tem um Hippo, por Exemplo Que Você Está Trazendo Novas Features Toda Hora.
Então, o que ele vai fazer? Ele sempre vai classificar como normal.
Então ele já vai pulando as etapas para você automaticamente.
Come back.
E se você pegar.
Aqui uma outra Edge a refund endpoint. Mesma coisa normal.
Porque já existam. Qual é a intenção? Eu quero adicionar assim, assim com a estrutura. Se ele vai quebrar nas Adrs.
Ele já cria tarefa.
Já faz um bind e já faz isso agora.
Buje a New Service for Reporting and I pô. Calma aí.
Então me dá os documentos.
Me dá intenção. Me dá a parada toda.
Que vocês acharem. Faz sentido. Legal.
Então você tem um fast normal e o full.
Faz sentido para nem sempre. Toda vez você ficar fazendo processo repetidas vezes.
Beleza.
Faz sentido, né?
Então tá. Então aqui eu vou botar para executar esse cara.
Então a gente vai fazer duas coisas. Eu vou botar ele para executar.
Então ele vai copiar aqui essas informações.
Olá. Agora ele começou a organizar o swing.
Sete.
Então, só para avisar para vocês o que aconteceu.
A nova versão do Task Spec.
Quebrou a integração com o converge. Então o que eu vou prometer para vocês.
Eu vou deixar o repositório mais uma semana aberto. Até semana que vem.
Porque o que eu vou fazer na verdade é. Eu vou corrigir tudo isso para ficar uma experiência.
Certeira para vocês.
E aí vocês podem baixar com a o três nove integrado com o converge perfeitamente.
Doc. If I could ask sweet bonitinhas. Aqui Dlt Ingestion Orquestrate. Ele vai colocar dentro da pasta do Cvg.
Então eu vou deixar aberto para vocês poderem.
Vê.
último post issues.
Então, por exemplo, minha fábrica, quando ela roda na outra conta que eu tenho.
Eu venho aqui, abro o app. Então é assim que eu verifico, tá? Uma das formas que eu verifico. Como Está Indo A Fábrica.
Havendo o app aqui.
Eu clico, por exemplo.
Aqui.
No feedback. Eu venho aqui.
Eu consigo ver as tarefas que estão sendo executadas.
Então eu basicamente.
Vejo daqui.
Vamos ver aqui.
Desks.
Essa é uma mídia. Essa é uma mídia. Tá vendo?
Já é um pouquinho maior.
Daqui a pouco, ele começa a atualizar. Quem vai ser o agente assinalado para poder fazer isso.
Ele vai adicionar as labels. é para ele fazer toda essa parte. Tá de controle pra gente.
Aí que ele vai. Ele vai embora.
A gente vai deixar aqui, fazendo o que ele vai fazer. Ele vai construir.
Todos os caras. Nível do um ao cinco.
Depois da nossa próxima tarefa. Aqui.
Vai ser o quê?
Escreveu seis do zero.
Que é um tipo novo que a gente nunca viu.
Tá? Então, o que aconteceu? A gente simplesmente recebeu um novo tipo.
Se a gente vier aqui dentro de Specs, tem um novo tipo seis aqui.
Que se chama chargeback.
Aí. ó, começou agora ele cria para cada tarefa. Uma Orc tree. Tá vendo? Que legal!
Ele começa a trabalhar.
Eu adoro isso.
Então isso é por padrão. Dentro do converge. Eles sempre cria.
O Work Tree.
E aí esse Work Tree.
Vai estar assinalado. A tarefa que vai ser executada e o Card vai ser atualizado aqui.
Ele faz isso para não conflitar.
Só que aí a parada de vocês falarem foda, é isso aqui, ó, porque muita gente acha que ele vai Fazer Isso De Serial Né.
Tem tarefas que ele vai fazer. Cereal.
Tem tarefas que ele vai fazer paralelo.
Por quê? Por isso que a gente fez a decomposição do Swelene.
Do docinholandes e Legs.
Porque aqui você consegue quebrar. Olha aí.
Pela dependência de uma da outra. Exatamente.
Então depois ele vai atualizando aqui.
Esse card esses cards, tá, ele vai.
Predicando aqui. E se a gente vier em testes.
Daqui a pouco a gente vai ver.
Esses caras. Moves aqui pra Donny.
Aí, voltando aqui depois que a gente terminar de escrever.
Todos os tipos do um ao cinco.
A gente vai fazer um tipo novo.
E olha só. Que legal. Esse tipo novo.
Esse tipo novo se chama Mechchan Charge Back.
I just meant that.
Ele tem um vale de mínimo, que é o caminho feliz.
Ele tem um vale de Boundary.
E tem exatos dois centavos. Ele tem o Malformage.
Que ele vem válido. O arquivo.
Ele tem.
O e mail do Ricardo. Falando como que vai ser? As escalas de tradução.
Fala que é um layout aqui desse arquivo.
A definição da tabela.
Yes top procedure que insere dentro.
Aqui. A gente tem os.
Tipos, os arquivos.
E aqui a gente tem os esperados, que são as verdades. Aquele arquivo. Eu espero esse valor daquele outro arquivo. Eu Espero Desse Valor.
Daquele outro arquivo. Eu espero esse valor. Então eu tenho um balde que são os documentos que eu preciso ter.
As regras, a Stop procedure e as definições.
Deus, tenho sempre os que são os arquivos. E para cada um desses tempos, eu tenho exatamente o resultado final dele.
E onde? Como ele faz o controle de cor. Ele vai usar. é boa.
Não expliquei. Não.
Eu tenho duas formas. Se eu não falar nada.
Ele vai usar a própria llm.
That se.
Usar o Task Mesh aí.
Ele vai tentar por padrão. Usa o Taskmatch para fazer.
Ele vai verificar se você tem algum plugin do Kimi ou do codec instalado, ou se você tem algum ipi configurado.
Se você não tiver nenhum deles.
Ele vai falar. Olha, não tenho.
Não tem que é instalar. E aí você instala.
E ele te dá a possibilidade de você escolher.
E aí você pode setar. Tem o arquivo de configuração que você seta.
Ou que você pede para ele setar. Obviamente que você fala. ó.
Quando for tarefas pequenas, executa esse modelo hoje. é assim, tá.
Quando tem tarefas pequenas. Executa esse modelo. Quando for tarefas médias, executa esse.
Quando for tarefas grandes, executa esse.
Então você pode escolher qual é o tipo de Gianning que você quer escolher.
Vai estar executando aqui.
Vamos ver se já tem alguma atualização. Ainda.
E daí vai. Depois que a gente fez isso?
A gente vai.
Da roda, tá.
Então, basicamente, o que funciona o Flywheel tá gente só pra vocês entenderem.
Will Fly Wheel. é para vocês poderem.
Coletar experiência.
E lições do que aconteceu.
Então, basicamente, quando você passa no loop, o converge já faz isso. Mas se você estiver criando o seu próprio loop.
Você pede para ele falar. Olha, toda vez que você passar pelo loop, o que você tem que fazer é No Final Você Guarda.
O que aconteceu. Mostra o que acontece.
E daí? Na verdade, o que ele vai fazer? Ele vai girar e vai achar a informação para você.
Vai guardar essas informações como lições. Já vi um exemplo aqui.
Eu não sei exatamente onde estão as lessons agora.
No topo da minha cabeça. Eu vou ter que lembrar onde está.
Isso, eu acho, aqui continuar as lições.
Ah, boa, Luiz. Ele só vai gerar as tarefas se ele estiver cem certeza que ela pode ser concluída, então.
Esse cenário não vai acontecer dele não conseguir executar, porque ele fez a decomposição.
Então ele nunca vai criar uma tarefa que ele não saiba o que vai fazer por causa da decomposição. Mas.
Tem uma coisa aqui que você falou, que com certeza é muito foda. Que é? Tá.
Ele pode falhar por outras coisas aqui.
Ele pode falhar por tempo. Ele pode falhar por interação.
Ele pode falhar, porque, na verdade, houve um erro intransiente em alguma outra sessão. Tentou pegar e vai dar.
O temporary na atividade.
Então existem algumas formas que vão acontecer se aquela tarefa que está sendo executada.
Ela depende das outras. Então.
é o que vai acontecer. Vai falhar.
Não vai começar as próximas, obviamente.
Quando essa tarefa falhar.
O que você vai fazer? Ele vai colocar na sua tela. A tarefa falhou por causa disso disso. E disso O Que Você Quer Fazer.
E aí você vai interagir com a Llm para ver qual o próximo passo aqui. ó.
Ponto cloud cab.
Acho que é this.
E tem os lessons. Learned.
Aqui. São as lições que eu aprendi.
Que eu aprendo constantemente, né?
Então, o que acontece aqui.
Qual é a grande sacada? Quando você roda o loop.
Que que vai acontecer? Ele vai sempre olhar essas lições. Então, coisas que ele já passou.
E muitas das vezes vai ter um caminho, ou vai ter uma Skill que ele carrega.
Então, por exemplo, se ele bate em algum problema lá? Que foi? Sei lá.
Valor numérico que ele teve algum problema e não conseguiu.
Você. Ele vai olhar quando ele passar no loop, que ele estiver fazendo isso. E vai falar. Opa, eu tenho memórias aqui.
Eu tenho lições que eu já aprendi.
Ele vai olhar e vai falar, pô, olha, tem uma lição de decimal aqui.
Dessa Skill que resolve esse problema.
Ele vem aqui e resolve o problema.
Esse repositório tá grande, velho.
Essas configurações com todas. Não converge.
A Lucia lá e dele. Mas aí você perde.
Quais são as configurações que eu tenho.
Eu quero fazer o setup do converge.
O que eu configuro. E ele vai te dar toda a informação dentro dele. Ele tem como se fosse. Não é Um Ll Mas Ele Tem Um Convergesque.
Você pode fazer perguntas para ele. Vou fazer o setup. Aí ele te traz uma experiência de setup.
Configura tudo que você quer. Primeiro instala no projeto, e você não tem mais que fazer nada.
Uma dúvida sobre o consumo de tokens no converge. Se a minha conta acabar no meio de uma task, que acontece.
Essa Task, ela para de ser executada.
E ela é dada como não completa hoje eu não tenho um sistema de memória que faz isso não no converge.
O Taskmatch tem algo parecido, mas não hoje. Ela falha.
Então, sei lá. Você está no meio.
Estourou sua assinatura lá.
E ela parou no meio. Ela vai falhar. Por quê? Porque ela é atômica ou tudo ou nada.
Aí? O que acontece, né?
Bem, você teve o Cloud que fez o que é um sign off dessa atividade.
Dessa atividade precisa ser reagerada.
E ela vai ser automaticamente até você vai falar. Opa falhou.
Beleza. Vou reigerar essa atividade, porque ele regera atividade.
Que ele regera atividade com novo Hitmec.
Uma nova chave. Porque da próxima vez que o outro agente vier.
Vai ser uma nova chave.
Wow, hoje, vendo essa estrutura que você montou, posso dizer que não precisa mais de create a agro e afins. Posso Usar Seus Projetos é Claro Mas Quero Adaptar A Sua Necessidade.
Sim, se dependendo de você estar usando Krue ai Agno, para fazer esse controle ou coisa assim.
Você pode fazer tudo via Skills e tudo pela Cli.
Então, independente de você usar aqui, você pode usar essa ideia que eu te falei.
Chat. Skill.
E se ela é? Se você tiver isso, você pode substituir para esses casos de uso aqui.
As in giants. Tá.
Assinatura aqui do cloud.
é.
Sessenta.
Acho que está tudo certo até o momento.
Atualizou aqui.
Ele geralmente atualiza no final.
Agora não sei se por causa.
Da atualização nova que eu fiz, que quebrou. Pode ser por causa disso. Também.
Beleza. Então agora, basicamente, esperar, executar.
Para a gente executar o Tipo seis. Deixa eu pensar. Se a gente consegue executar o Tipo seis isolado.
Conseguimos. é um novo recurso, não é?
A gente pode fazer isso também, tá? Então a gente vai fazer o seguinte.
Para a gente ver o tipo seis.
A gente vai.
Vim aqui. Vai abrir.
No Work Tree.
Vou chamar de.
Work Tree.
Seis.
Age trade.
E aí eu vou colar.
Aí. Que eu vou fazer.
Que eu vou fazer com.
Grock.
Já passado. Passe oito inteiro.
Visitar o tipo seis.
O que ele vai fazer, tá.
Ele vai fazer a Dark Factory inteira. Então, basicamente, eu falei o seguinte, tá.
E aí eu vou dar uma dica muito foda aqui.
Está vendo que aqui no Prompt eu precisei. Não precisei. Mas eu especifiquei o seguinte.
The olhar. O Spec, tipo, seis.
Você vai executar o converge.
Para ganhar consensos.
Executar o Task Spec.
Vai fazer? O Binding vai verificar. Vai validar e vai escrever tudo. Fim a fim.
E vai colocar isso no linear.
Beleza.
O que você pode fazer.
Que foi o que eu fiz aqui. ó.
Eu criei um comando.
Barratices alto. Tá vendo?
Então olha só. Que foda. Eu criei um comando.
Que basicamente era assim. Basicamente era assim. Não é desse jeito. ó, só pra você ver como é que eram as minhas madrugadas.
Eu vim aqui te se exalto.
Para vocês verem a cabeça explodindo. Agora, eu chegava no Spec.
Pô. Qual Spec que eu recebi? Eu recebi esse Spec aqui.
Do cliente para traduzir.
E acabou. Era isso.
Era isso. Essa era a minha Dark Factory. é isso que eu tinha que fazer de trabalho.
E daí ele passava por todos os processos.
Sozinhos. Então aqui eu estou mostrando um prompt.
Mas dá real. Que você pode fazer? O quê? Dar um barra.
Fabric? Sei lá. Alto.
E você só cola o que você quer? E ele vai fazer todos os pedaços para você automaticamente.
Eu só tô vendo o Thiago mandando foda aqui.
Luan. Quando você trabalha com várias Lives, você tem a mesma config base em todos os Mdfs de cada Lm.
é? Basicamente, uso sempre o Cloud. Uma vez usei o Kim. Acabei bagunçando um pouco o projeto.
Você pode criar um Setup Harness. Vou te dar uma dica, tá.
Cria uma Skill.
Queria mais Skill no projeto.
Que faz o setup de todos os Harders para você.
Para você nunca mais passar por isso.
Então, o que é isso? Pô? Entrou no projeto. Usa esse Skill como se fosse um setup.
Configura para mim. O que ela vai fazer? Ela vai criar o Agents Md.
Ela vai criar o Cloud Md.
Ela vai criar lá o ponto. Cloud Folder vai criar lá o ponto Cloud Grock Folder.
E aí você pede para cada um estruturar do jeito que você quer ficar bonitinho do mesmo jeito. Então, quando Qualquer Lima Entrar No Repositório.
Ele não vai sofrer com esse tipo de coisa.
é? Tem que ser preguiçoso. Pô.
E aí eu só tava assim mandando Barry Spec.
E é isso. Deixa eu pedir para ele continuar me explicar aqui.
Aqui. Agora. Ele vai executar.
Minha filha.
Vai lá, autônomo. Então, basicamente, o que acontecia comigo na Curv.
Foi isso? Eu pegava os arquivos, botava para executar. Ficava fazendo outras coisas aqui.
Que eu nem queria automatizar isso. Não falei: Ah, nem vou automatizar isso. Não.
Eu deixava lá fazendo.
Ia fazer outras coisas. Demorava, sei lá, vinte.
Trinta minutos ou eu fazia melhor. Eu abria tres work tres e botava três para o resultado. Uma vez.
E aí, por isso que eu comecei a usar o químia.
Porque eu comecei a fazer isso. Repet.
E aí essa área aí eu via os arquivos que eram mais simples. Eu tentava fazendo que eu fazia muito bem.
Então eu comecei a usar duas llms no mesmo projeto. Foi daí que eu comecei a usar multi hardness.
Então eu comecei a usar Butcher aos quatro meses atrás.
Uma coisa que não está clara para mim, é o seu processo. Pode administrar vários projetos diferentes.
Com contexto diferentes, sendo resolvidos com Ia e, ainda assim, garantia que tudo está correto.
Tá? Então vamos pegar dois projetos, né?
Dois projetos têm.
Entradas diferentes.
Uma Black Box de converge que vai ser a mesma coisa para todos. Concordam.
E uma saída que tem que ter uma validação.
Qual é a grande sacada? Como que você gerencia isso?
Eu hoje gerencia dessa forma.
Inclusive eu estou mudando minha forma de gerenciamento está sendo assim agora.
Eu crio um time para cada fábrica. é, é isso mesmo. Chupa.
é isso mesmo. Eu tenho um time.
Que tem um factory lead.
O Research. Um backlog.
Agora vocês vão pirar um deve um teste.
E um document.
Então, basicamente.
Esse cara tá olhando meu repositório de cima.
E aí eu falo. Kill.
Bring me.
The Latest Updates About the Project.
And.
Ask Inc.
To Provide me.
A Summary.
About What Happened.
This week.
E aí você cria uma rotina para isso.
Eu estou citando agora, porque antes eles ficavam divididos aí, o certo é uma rotina. Então eu tenho um time Que Conversa Com Todo Mundo Eles Se Conversam.
Então, por exemplo, o que o mandou? Uma tarefa.
O índice pegou essa tarefa.
E fez um Equally update para mim.
Chipou a tarefa no linear.
Olha que depressivo.
Puxou a tarefa no línea.
Volta aqui!
Aí. O que o mandou para o Slate.
Revisou.
Em que não aprovou. E ele está falando. Olha.
O teste que mexendo tá em Progress. Então, se eu vier aqui.
No Task Spec, que eu estou fazendo os testes finais agora.
Eu estou testando.
Eu tenho duas pull. Requires abertas aqui. ó.
Que falhar.
Eu vou consertar esse cara. Mas a ideia que eu vou ter um time fazendo isso, então.
Só para voltar aqui. Eu não sei o que vocês estão escrevendo, mas deixa eu terminar o processo que eu mostro.
Cara. Isso aqui é o supra sumo do supra sumo, tá? Quem tá fazendo isso aqui? é assim.
Times que estão trabalhando com o grok bot no nível que eu estou também. Então é assim.
Você tem o cockpit.
Chama de. Eu vou publicar para vocês um pedaço do meu await. Tá.
Por causa que você perguntou Davi tá.
Então eu divido o Eyed em três partes. Calma aí. Vocês querem ver isso aqui enquanto tá fazendo cranking? Eu Quero Ver Outra Coisa.
Vamos ver aqui.
Ah, tá, beleza. Então, olha só.
Eu tenho três níveis no Idols, tá? A primeira se chama.
Cockpit.
A segunda se chama autônomos.
E a terceira.
Se chama Dark Factory.
E aí, como que eu tenho feito hoje.
Dá só para entender o nível de loucura aqui que eu.
Na verdade, eu chamo de facto. E só, né.
Então, qual o meu entendimento? Eu trabalhando nos meus projetos há muitos anos.
Eu começo um projeto.
é muito doido. Esses Frameworks aqui tá. Vocês me falam. O que vocês acham? Isso faz sentido.
Aí você fala. Ah, mas é complexo demais. é porque a vida é complexa para mim. Então eu preciso de Coisas Para Resolver Meus Problemas Então Assim Eu Começo O Projeto.
Então eu vou lá entender o projeto.
Então vamos supor que eu peguei um projeto chamado Uc North Windpay.
Beleza. Esse é o projeto.
Aí. O projeto está aqui. Aí eu vou entender.
Aí. Eu vou chegar no projeto aqui. Eu vou abrir o super engineering.
Eu estou dando. Eu estou dando.
Isso aqui é literalmente o meu molho secreto, tá? Ninguém tem acesso a isso aqui. Isso aqui é como eu trabalho.
Beleza. Então eu abro super engineering.
Aí. Eu começo a entender o projeto. Aí eu uso o quê? Que eu uso meu combo, né?
Desk Spec para gerar as tarefas. Atual.
Vamos pegar aqui. Assim o aise para decompor.
O problema? Task Spec.
Para gerar as tarefas.
E aí, se isso for uma fábrica, ou se for algo muito complexo.
Eu uso, converge.
Mas eu.
Esses dois normalmente.
Beleza. Aí eu vou lá, corto os negócios. Tá funcionando. Não sei o que aí as tarefas começam a aparecer lá.
Eu vou habilitando o backlog. Vou entendendo. Vou fazendo aí. Eu vou me tirar do loop.
Aí. Eu retiro do loop.
Aí quando eu me tiro do loop.
Eu saio do Super Engineering.
E aí eu vou para o Simax.
Aí eu abro projeto no Siem.
E eu já tenho esse processo de automação. Que está acontecendo.
Tenho. Abro aqui o projeto no Simux. Olha, coisa linda.
Ele fazendo tudo. Autônomo.
Passe um passe agora. Sim, vocês vão ver o Cvg. Delícia.
Olha que foda. Um, dois, três, quatro, cinco. Agora Sim, é o meu Cvg bichão. Oito.
Tudo construindo a feature inteira.
Desculpa, fod.
Voltando onde eu estava.
Aí. Eu abro o Cimax.
Aí? O sim Box está aqui.
Aqui! Abro, Cimax.
E aí o Cibox. Agora eu trabalho muito pouco tempo nele. Porque eu fico aqui do lado.
Ele já está rodando mais autônomo. Eu estou vendo as tarefas. ó, executa as tarefas, tais.
Faz tal coisa. Ele fica aqui fazendo isso aqui. ó, isso aqui. Eu não preciso dar mais atenção para o Projeto Do Jeito Que Eu Dou.
Então agora eu já estou saindo um pouco mais do controle. Eu estou deixando esse gate agora.
Automatizado. Porque quem automatizou isso aqui.
O Seawise Tech. Ele automatizou isso para mim.
Aí quando eu chego no nível em que eu já conheço projeto. Ele já está.
Rodando e eu não preciso mais olhar para ele. Eu vou para a fábrica. Aí eu trago o grok bot.
Antes eu tentar fazer isso com o Hermes Agents ou com o Openclop. Eu não consegui fazer bem.
E agora o Grokbox faz muito bem. Isso.
Então o grok bot. Eu venho aqui.
Cria um time.
Certo? A responsabilidade de cada um do time.
E aí?
Cada um dos tem uma responsabilidade. Então, Kill.
Ele é o Factory Lead. Ele é como se fosse o Pm.
Eu tenho prob que vai fazer a pesquisa que eu falei para vocês. Que tem o Indian que faz pesquisa. Então Eu Tenho Um Agente Que Faz Pesquisa Para Mim.
Ele já sabe a intenção do projeto. Ele vai lá, busca na rede, faz pesquisas na Internet e traz para mim.
Coisas para implementar. Aí eu tenho o Slate, que é o backlog. Ele vai lá e registra essas informações no linear para mim.
Aí uma vez. Uma hora que ele registra.
Wright, pega.
E faz a escrita da Poor Requests. Faz a escrita do código.
E faz um pull requests. Quando o Pull requests finaliza.
O acei. Pega, faz um teste, roda o Ci. Verifica se está tudo certo.
E aí ele aceita ou recusa.
é isso?
Legal. E Diego. Essa ideia aqui do Frankly Big Gibret e do Clarice Bleacher.
Sempre que há um trabalho difícil para fazer, eu atribuo a um homem preguiçoso.
Ele com certeza encontrará uma maneira fácil de fazer totalmente.
é, faz tipo, duas semanas que o Grock lançou. é tipo isso.
Daí. Você já vê como que eu estou.
No Bleeding Edge, né? Não é nem Karine Edge. Não.
Ele já é. Ele já tem Brief Spec aqui.
Cara pra Factory.
Para ficar barato. Eu pagaria o Kim.
O que me é muito foda. Assim.
Na minha humilde opinião, que me performa como oposs cinco tranquilamente, principalmente pelo Test Spec, que cria as utilidades.
As unidades. Então, assim se eu fosse escolher, eu escolheria sempre três.
Se não puder, tres, eu teria o Cloud primeiro. Depois eu teria o codec.
Sujeitos a modificações, dependendo do meu humor.
You kimi.
Se você puder escolher.
Uma Open e uma fechada.
Eu escolheria o Codex.
Porque ele tem o.
Ele tem.
Ele tem uma assinatura muito generosa. Vai fazer muita coisa com ele.
E escolheria o quê? Me.
Pudesse escolher só um, eu escolheria o Chat Gpt, o codec.
Mas o como perfeito aqui seria Claudia Kimicodex.
O Grok. Eu tô muito feliz com ele. Gosto bastante, mas eu ainda.
Eu ainda estou me adaptando a ele.
Tá.
Oh, latest test back.
Está com risco. Isolation Passage.
Eles registaram a tarefa foi para mim.
O oceano conseguiu fazer isolação, tá? Por quê?
Eu acho isso muito magia negra, na minha opinião.
Os Bots conversam entre eles. é muito escrito. Isso.
Quer ver? Cadê.
Quando eles têm interação.
Eles abriram uma thread aqui. Deixa eu ver se eu.
Se eu vejo em algum lugar aqui. ó.
Eu acho. Eu sou muito magia negra, velho velho. Isso aqui é a parada mais disruptivo que eu já vi desde o Cloud.
Desde o Cloud. De longe, tá.
Então eles começam a trabalhar.
Está conversar.
Para chegar num acordo.
Então marquei eles aqui.
O Remains é bom. Também gosta dele?
é o problema do Grok Heavy, que é trezentos do letra. Ele é caro.
Mas agora eles estão expandindo o Grok Bot para outras assinaturas. Então está indo para Proska agora.
Então aqui é como se você tivesse um time, né? é como se você tivesse um time, não é você ter um time.
Então, na hora que você já está confortável, que você entende o processo que você entende? A fábrica.
E assim por diante. Você faz. Por exemplo, eu vou dar outro Nugget para você. Isso aqui eu estou mostrando Para Vocês Ninguém, Nunca Viu Tá Ninguém, Ninguém.
Nem o Datasip. Então eu não fiquei com raiva. Tá, pessoal? Depois vou mostrar pra vocês. Mas.
Eu peço para toda semana.
O link gerava mim um documento.
Então deixa eu te mostrar aqui qual documento ele me gera.
Só um minuto.
Esse documento é o primeiro documento que ele me gera inicial.
De tudo que ele fez.
E aí eu tenho vários estilos. Quando eu vou viajar, o compacto e assim por diante.
E depois ele começa a me mandar somente atualizações. ó Travelers Operation Field Guide.
Então eu vou lendo.
Aí. Eu vou fazendo anotações.
Vou entendendo o projeto cada vez mais. Vou trabalhando nele e assim por diante. Porque eu não consigo entender todas As Features Que Foram Implementadas.
Eu tenho sempre uma ideia. Eu sei o que é, mas eu não sei o nível.
Lá dentro. E como eu sou um cara muito chato.
Eu quero entender, né?
Eu vou tentar entender. Ali pedaço a pedaço. Então ele gera esses documentos para mim.
Então, cara a imaginação.
Oh, right writes the Fix I see Only Scorsen.
Trump Block. Eu sei.
Trump block, lua trinta e quatro, que é o problema.
Que a gente teve no Taskmask Slolution. Você aceitou.
Mas ele não respondeu. O que a gente tem que fazer aqui?
It starts on task and then say scores again like clean accepts again except with gaps does not merge weight.
Seis centos. If You Want.
Let's Fix that.
E o que é legal disso aqui. Assim, se vocês conseguirem entender toda a lombra. Mas.
Você está no seu celular?
Ou você está em qualquer lugar. E você tem uma fábrica que você já conhece.
E você tem um time fazendo para você.
Eu acho isso aqui assim. ó.
A parada. Mais foda.
Que vai me ajudar em vários outros controles que eu tenho da minha vida, que já acelerou.
Gigantescamente.
Essas informações.
Desculpa, eu estou desviando um pouco, mas só para.
Dá mais visão para vocês, tá?
Aí, Lucas. Aí eu já não tenho mais esse problema aí. Eu deixo eles lidarem com esse negócio. O que é Legal Aqui é O Seguinte.
Todos eles compartilham uma máquina.
Lá. Então a máquina é a mesma. Então, se eu entrar aqui.
Do Chief of Staff, por exemplo.
O que essa máquina tem. Ela tem.
Obviously, abre aqui.
Ele tem o Chrome.
Ele tem.
Files aqui, onde ele armazena tudo isso. Então ele controla. Ele sabe tudo porque ele vai guardando aqui e ele Tem Um Chat Componente Tá Vendo.
Olá. Tô bonitinho. Ele tem tudo.
Workspace dele.
E ele tem a Celi.
Por exemplo, I still my pai nessa cli.
Entendeu? Olha que isso foda.
Então eles têm acesso a tudo velho. E eu posso gravar uma Skill aqui, se eu quiser.
Ensinando ele para fazer alguma coisa. é muito doido. Isso aqui é.
Inspiração total na minha. Nunca vi nada igual.
Olá. Estão trabalhando aqui? ó.
Say the right take lua trinta e quatro. Ele vai olhar agora. Qual foi o problema?
De lua.
Aí ele vai.
Corrigir. E agora o Wright está trabalhando. Se eu vier no Wright.
Está cozinhando aqui? ó.
Aí. é uma outra história sobre isso. Que depois eu compartilho com vocês sobre efetividade disso realmente na prática. Tá.
Que é muito assustador. Mais ainda.
Então aqui ó, sobretudo.
Vamos ver aqui. Modern.
Ainda está executando. Não, calma aí.
Okay, está fora da sessão.
Joy. Test dezasseis.
Dois delegantes.
O que? Que? Eu não estou vendo? Esses outros caras aqui.
Aqui é seis. Vamos ver se a gente acha seis aqui.
Modern Sticky House.
Desculpa, Ingestium. Src. Não Film.
Seis. Hitler Model passa esquema Writer.
Click housing, dlt.
Dbt.
Tá aqui. Charge Back.
Creates, validação está escrevendo. Ainda.
But.
Ele tá fazendo um bindinho aqui.
Vamos. Vamos ver o Darkster. Com certeza. A gente tem que ver o Darkster.
Own Tasks.
é que eu tenho que falar? Porque ele misturou o Task Spec com Converge, tá? Eu tenho que trabalhar, inclusive nisso.
But. A gente começou com o Task Spec e virou. Converge. Por isso que ele tá dando uma alumbrada aqui.
Ah, uma coisa aqui. ó, olha só isso. Aqui.
Pedir um gol, né.
Tá vendo?
Saca só!
Você vê o que aconteceu aqui?
Foda, né.
Ele tirou o perfeito gol pra mim.
Hi, velho. Minha vida é muito boa. Você tá doido, gente.
Isso que eu ainda estou no meio da tempestade. Se eu tô me sentindo meio louco, imagino vocês. Boa sorte.
Emma. Cada um com seus problemas, né? Eu ainda estou.
Encontrando minha cabeça, como eu organizo tudo isso. Tá.
Mas aqui eu criei um transforme de gol.
Então, toda vez que eu apertar esse comando, opt tres.
Ele reescreve o que eu escrevi.
Para acertar, para criar um gol perfeito. Um objetivo perfeito. Você está doido? Isso aqui é delícia demais.
E dele setor, né?
Hoje está bizarro, né? Hoje eu só trouxe uns nuggets.
Gigante para vocês comerem.
Aqui, voltando sobre.
Mas acho que. Acho que é a vida real. Tá.
A gente vai de um lado para outro contexto.
Está vivendo? Essa era da loucura, né?
Então aqui.
O tices on board.
Ele é um alias. O que ele faz? Ele roda oito estágios.
Ele gera os pacotes. Trabalha no Bronze Chipa. Dark Factory.
Então, basicamente, foi o comando que eu criei para poder abstrair todas essas paradas.
Deixar aqui.
Eu acho muito delícia isso, velho. Olha, agora.
Donny.
Tá? Você está alumbrando. Tá.
Calma aí. Onde eu estou? Ah, tá, desculpa. Eu tô aqui.
Gol sete.
All tasks under tal completed into and done.
No Remaining Tasks Are Associated Linear Cards reflected.
Lindo. Vamos lá, Structure Match. Agora você foi, né? O Hatazana.
Tá. Agora Sim.
Beleza, rato de laboratório.
Chama.
Vai crancando aí que agora eu só tô terminando a planta pra gente ver o fim a fim.
E down Call it a day.
Enquanto isso, deixo passar.
Só chicote.
é o Hermes Bot. é bom.
Eu já testei todos. O Hermes é bom, mas nada se compara com o Grokbot. Grokbot é.
Você sente que você está chitando no nível mais chitador que existe do mundo. é muito unfair.
Ele é uma vantagem que eu nem gostaria de mostrar para vocês. Para ser honesto.
Porque essa era a única coisa assim. Tipo, realmente vantagem.
Parada que ninguém não usa. Assim. Tipo tal.
Mas isso aqui é foda Vel.
Então o meu grock bot usa a sua fábrica.
Sim, não aí. Eu tenho que entrar aqui nas paradas das configurações, né?
Mas eu criei um projeto. Eu criei um time dentro do Grokboch.
E esse time é para trabalhar no projeto do Task Spec, na Fábrica do Test Spec. Então automatizei.
A automação sacou.
Que nem o Thiago falou. Que loucura. O Boy é.
E automatizei a automação.
Então eu estou fazendo Dog Fury.
Eu estou alimentando o produto com o próprio produto, entendeu?
Então eu criei uma fábrica do Task Spec.
Melhorando o test pack.
Depois eu vou criar uma.
Uma fábrica.
Do converge para melhorar o converge.
Depois eu vou criar uma fábrica do projeto que você está para melhorar o seu projeto.
Então você cria teams de fábricas.
Muito doido, né?
Outro nível. Eu também acho.
Não. E você criou umas paradas aqui. Muito foda. Tipo.
Eles trabalham. Por exemplo, no meu seco de Brain.
E assim por diante. Mas uma coisa que eu acho legal aqui.
é que, por exemplo.
Ainda não terminei, mas pô.
Eu peço para ele ler todos os meus Slacks para aprender.
Criar uma Skill de como eu me comunico. E aí ele começa a responder a galera.
Então, tipo assim, eu já tô testando isso, né.
Ele manda pra mim aqui primeiro. Eu valido. Dou a Sept. Ele escreve lá para o meu chefe. Faz.
Resumo semanal. Faz tudo pra mim, velho.
Tipo outra coisa.
Com a Manu.
Exercícios com a Manu.
Academia. Meus treinos!
Esse aqui é mais particular, mas pô Youtube. Análise Youtube. Ah, eu tenho aqui, por exemplo, o Pulse, que me mandou, inclusive hoje.
Algumas coisas. Novidades para poder estudar, então, assim.
Está fazendo as paradas. Muito, muito fodas. Eu ainda estou experimentando muita coisa. E agora.
Fala assim. Quero fritar a minha mente. Escreve aí pra vocês.
Da fritada que eu não vou sofrer sozinho, né?
Botar tudo para sofrer aqui também. Porque é assim.
Isso porque vocês vão me deixar sem voz.
Mas beleza. Então chupa aqui.
Vou dar pra vocês o ouro do ouro. Toma aí.
O diretório do Grok Bot com tudo.
Com os agentes, já. Tudo pronto.
Estão bem?
Toma.
Então toma.
é Rafael. Eles, infelizmente, os botes compartilham uma máquina. Então eles trabalham. Todo mundo lá.
Então quando você loga.
Uma vez no seu e mail. Todos os botes utilizam isso. é uma máquina compartilhada com.
Com Shared Context com a raiva em Mind. Então eles compartilham com memórias e tudo lá dentro.
Então eles têm uma máquina que eles compartilham.
Eu preciso queimar minha mente. é fod.
Depois. Eu queria falar do que eu nunca falo para vocês, mas aí é um assunto mais sensível.
O quanto eu consegui aumentar a minha renda na empresa.
O quanto eu consegui aumentar minha velocidade no trabalho.
O quanto eu comecei a trabalhar em outras coisas ao mesmo tempo.
O quanto eu comecei a ganhar mais em dólar em outros projetos ao mesmo tempo, sem ter nenhum impacto na minha vida.
E isso tudo por causa dessa loucura aqui.
Então isso aqui é tudo. Para eu poder conseguir dar vazão ao meu backlog que eu nunca consegui em dezessete anos de tecnologia.
Eu estou chegando num ponto que eu estou zerando meu backlog inteiro. Você tem noção? O que é isso?
Cara, todo todo.
Então assim eu finalmente estou entrando no processo que eu tô conseguindo zerar.
Eu tô conseguindo fazer muitas coisas ao mesmo tempo, com uma qualidade absurda.
Entregar tudo a um Point. E ainda está.
Muito bem com o sistema atualizado, lendo os documentos no final do dia me atualizando. Então eu estou criando Flow. Ainda Estou Me Adaptando Com Adoles.
Então, para quem fizer parte.
Cande o datasip. E quem fizer parte da formação.
Tá? Então eu vou deixar aqui para vocês. Isso aí.
Quem todo mundo que fizer formação e tiver no datasip.
Eu vou fazer um workshop.
Tá? Eu vou chamar de workshop. Eu vou chamar de Master Class.
Que eu vou mostrar o eus para você. E vou mostrar como que eu configuro.
O meu ecossistema inteiro.
Eu vou pegar um caso de uso de ecossistema, e eu vou configurar ele inteiramente, tá.
Desde o projeto, até ele virar autônomo até ele virar fábrica. Como que eu tenho seco de Brem, como que Eu Me Organizo Como Um Todo.
Então, quem tiver a formação. Eu já até anotei aqui.
E o Datasip. Eu vou fazer uma apresentação sobre isso para vocês. Então vou ter que fazer para o Datasip de qualquer jeito.
E eu estendo pra dar informação.
Oi, Luan. Tudo que a gente quer é cliente feliz para resolver. Como você faz para capturar.
Corretamente a intenção passar isso. Então aí que ficou a parte mais fácil do rolê, né? Porque agora que a Gente Consegue Automatizar Tudo Isso Agora Eu Posso Respirar.
E eu posso literalmente. Finalmente, pela primeira vez, falar assim, velho, eu nem vou pensar. Nada, técnico, eu vou. Tô Cagando Pra Tudo Porque.
Porque você está com clientes. Eu vou entender.
Então, na verdade, é aprimorar os seus soft skills.
E aprimorar a sua forma de como você vai capturar. Como você vai entender o problema? Como você vai coletar a intenção.
E aí, uma vez que você tem isso, o resto fica fácil.
Caralho! Ratasa Ratolino, Rate, Super Rato, Rato, manager.
é Marcelo.
Infelizmente, eu não acho o tempo que eu gostaria de dar para minha filha.
Mas eu vou chegar lá. Eu tô fazendo tudo isso também. Por causa disso.
é engraçado, né? A Manu. Ela queria ser sempre benção na vida, né?
Eu pelo menos vejo assim independentemente. E aí, cara?
A gente cheia de preocupação, cara. Como que vai ser? Como.
E cara, eu, em um ano de Manu.
A mão. Não vai fazer amanhã. Ela faz oito meses.
Eu dobrei meu salário. Basicamente.
E eu me sinto a pessoa mais produtiva. E eu consigo dar atenção assim. Claro que não. A atenção que Eu Gostaria De Dar Pra Ela Mas Eu Consigo Estar Com Ela.
Três, quatro vezes ali. No dia.
Eu tiro a parte da manhã pra ficar com ela um pouquinho. Uma hora, duas horas.
Ainda na hora do almoço, você sai um pouquinho com ela. Cinco horas é sagrado. Eu saio com ela.
Então eu consigo acompanhar minha filha. Então isso é uma coisa.
Muito foda. Sabe, filha. Muito bem. Sou assim.
Traz muito isso.
Eu sugiro beber.
Olha, eu sugeriria.
Tem? Quantas pessoas aqui? Oitenta e um, né.
Eu sugeriria.
Olhar o Adilson. O Adilson é um cara muito foda. Já trabalhei com ele. é um cara também, que eu Considero Fora Da Curva.
Faz um grupo cara no Whatsapp, e depois a gente move isso pra algum lugar.
Se esse grupo realmente tiver tração. Eu não sou de aceitar grupo. Eu não sou de entrar em grupo, mas.
Faz um grupo divulga um grupo legalzinho de insights. Não sei o que.
E aí dá para vocês testarem coisas, fazer coisas. Eu acho que é uma coisa legal de vocês fazerem. Eu faria, tá.
Rádio sequer paisão. Você, Phil, que tem que aprender muito. Ainda.
No rolê do pai. Eu ainda estou muito longe, mas é assim, né?
A questão é a gente correr.
Acho que a fábrica parou.
Não parou. Não tá aqui. Filme forte.
A seis parou. Olha, fizemos tudo.
Donny. Tipo seis instalado.
Fia. Fee.
But a hora da verdade.
Tá aqui, ó Cis. Criado consenso feito.
Tudo criado, foda, né.
Gostoso. Isso aqui.
Jonathan é bom. Você conseguiu colocar pra dormir, né?
é bom demais.
Vamos ver o Degxtere.
Para ver se o bichão é rasgado mesmo pela primeira vez.
Caraca. Não sei mais escrever. Não.
Exatamente. A água é sobre via.
Sobrevia.
Via Docker.
Curiosidade. Alguém aqui.
Alguém aqui já testou o Gpt.
Vinte. Bi, local.
Se alguém já testou minha visa aqui.
é gente. Infelizmente, funcionou. Tá.
Só tenho isso para falar para vocês.
A gente tem que executar.
Mas ele vai rodar aqui. Eu pedi pra ele rodar.
Mas ele criou o Lined. Todinho bonitinho aqui, ó.
é a vida é assim, né, Chitano?
Até eu vou usar. Vai, eu vou entrar também.
Por favor, coloquem um ícone bonitinho.
Parada assim. Legal pra gente usar.
Eu vou entrar aqui para ficar vendo vocês.
Fully.
Na hora que eu não entro em grupo, tá? Olha só pra vocês verem que eu não tô mentindo. Olha O Tanto De Grupo Que Eu Tenho.
Eu tenho quatro grupos, eu acho.
Do Datasip ou do The Plumbers.
Os membros fundadores e da Pitcher.
Só pra você ter ideia que eu não tenho grupo. Eu não uso grupo.
Ah, então.
Beleza.
Me pedir para ele executar. Agora vamos ver se a gente já está executando.
Ah, vou ter esperar, só isso aqui. Acabar.
Enquanto isso, eu vou fazer uma coisa aqui que eu preciso fazer rapidinho.
Open folder. Finder.
Ebooks.
Need to modify it Tv.
Share.
Airdrop.
Like a bouquet.
Eu sempre tenho orgulho de vocês. Quem fica até o final, não tem nem como não ter. Quem assiste.
Não. Calma aí, irmão. Não era pra cá. Não.
Para cá.
Olha.
Eu gosta, né?
Caraca que top? Eu citei. All my pie.
Com o Gpt.
Não. Calma aí. Com o olhama Gpt. Oss vinte Bi.
E o Olhama três Cold, trinta, bi.
Para testar offline quando eu estiver nove anos, vinte e cinco horas de voo. Que eu vou fazer agora?
Para ver se o bicho dá para dar.
Uma chapada no meu maczinho. Aqui.
Isso é legal. Eu aviso para vocês se funcionar realmente legal.
Beleza.
Vamos ver.
Quem vai falar, foda, quem vai xingar aí?
Ninguém. Vamos ver um foda gente. Vamos! Final do dia.
Os dados sendo materializados no negócio bonitinho.
Está sendo executado.
Blah. Processo de reconciliação bateu.
Verificando com Gold.
E aí, gente? Vou dar dez minutos para alguém falar alguma coisa aí no máximo que eu preciso ir embora, correndo. E aí.
O que vocês acharam. Fala no Cloud aí pra mim que eu já não aguento mais falar. Pelo amor de Deus.
Espero que minha voz volte no sábado na segunda, porque fudeu.
E aí, Wilker só quer paz. Tá em paz agora, irmão.
Oh hello sem, palavras estava hoje me deixou calado hoje eu fiquei calado porque eu fiquei reflexivo cara pensar que no início do ano, passado, eu não, sabia nem o que era, um token pra você ter uma, ideia.
Caralha. é muita coisa.
E, assim.
Alguém me apresentou, teus primeiros cursos ali que eu comecei.
E mergulhei a cabeça em fundamentos mergulhei a, cabeça praticar ou seja na empresa praticamente databrics hoje a gente tem acesso além do copilty.
Paddle.
Conseguir ser uma referência na criação de pipelines e apps fazer todo o monorip, então eu tenho criado meu projetinho ali de estudo ele, é um projetinho pequenininho mas, é melhor projeto para tudo.
E cara sem palavras o, ponto é o seguinte o que eu já faço aqui hoje é praticamente uma agulha no palheiro para tudo, que eu, vejo aqui.
E só que o que eu vejo aqui é o, ponto de um norte para onde eu sonhar e para onde eu caminhar então assim cara só te agradecer te desejar uma, boa viagem recuperação de saúde e sucesso, no seu trabalho lá cara sem, palavras.
Amém. Muito obrigado. Valeu, Wilker. é sempre bom ter você.
Eu acompanho a sua evolução. E realmente é bizarro, porque eu lembro quando você entrou na formação do Spark.
E eu olho hoje.
O quanto você saiu daquela pessoa para essa pessoa.
Então, obviamente que é tudo graças a você.
E é muito legal ver essa evolução. E a questão, né? Quem procura acha.
Thing.
Então você continua consumindo. E eu acho que é isso.
O treinamento te traz. O que você falou para mim perfeitamente, que eu não consegui explicar.
Ele te dá o norte e o norte vale dinheiro pra caralho. No final do dia.
é assim. ó, olha pra cá.
Vai por aqui. E aí, cara? Só você seguir aqui que eu tenho certeza que vai dar. Bom, tá. Obrigado Aí Por Sempre Acreditar.
Substant ideas só para completar rapidinho esse curso eu consegui acompanhar até certa medida depois eu parei mas o que o meu foco, dele não é nem, reproduzir. Mas é tentar capturar o modelo mental, esse tem sido sempre o meu objetivo agora.
é isso. E se você pensar nisso, essa é a forma mais inteligente do conteúdo.
Esquece o técnico. Captura o meu processo mental.
Ice.
E tenta olhar isso, somar com o seu e criar algo muito melhor. Então essa é a ideia. Realmente é O Processo Mental Como é Isso.
Se você aprendeu isso aí, filho. Aí a ferramenta vira qualquer coisa. Porque você.
Crio. Converge em qualquer lugar. Faz o que quiser, Linux, Mac, se é com Hermes Bot. Mas se você entendeu qual a ideia.
Entrou na mente. Aí se implementa exatamente isso.
Bom muito obrigado.
Valeu, Newton. Sempre também. Aí, cara. é outro guerreiro.
Yeah especially i'm a community.
Eu tenho, um.
Então vocês estão conseguindo me escutar e me ver bem.
Mhm.
Rapaz é até.
Depoimento aqui que eu vou fazer, mas é rápido primeiro, agradecer.
Você cara você está sendo luz aqui não só na minha vida. Por exemplo que eu vou dar o testemunho mas, eu acho que naquele todo mundo que conhece teu trabalho aí, a forma que você conduz seus cursos não só a sua.
E, a iniciativa mas é perceptível seu prazer cara, de passar conhecimento isso é muito foda.
Eh e cara, hoje eu recebi, um presente assim espetacular e é, fruto.
Desconhecimento que você está passando para a gente eu comentei com vocês aqui não no, podcast mas eu não lembro. Se foi na semana ide enfim que eu, passei por um layoff.
E eu nunca tinha enfrentado isso na vida.
And tatuaí também há um bom tempo em tecnologia e nunca tinha passado por, um layoff na vida e, passei a primeira vez cara hoje o fruto hoje aconteceu, fruto de toda essa construção desde março ali.
Da formação né.
Caralho! Que massa! Até arrepiei aqui.
E, hoje eu recebi, um sim cara hoje para, voltar ao mercado e é, fruto disso aqui cara.
Que legal! Que legal! Parabéns.
Juro, por deus e como obrigado obrigado e como o wilker falou é umas, palavras, ficaram, marcadas para mim quando, você falou que você falou foi o seguinte. Quando você hoje além de você, claro ter uma expertise uma bagagem que é legal.
Importante mas quando você entende.
O negócio e o processo.
Where soft i.
Só vai.
E eu senti nas entrevistas que eu tenho feito, que cada vez. Eu melhorei nesse aspecto, de naturalidade de, passar o conhecimento mas a reação de quem escuta no início eu tive muita dificuldade que eu tive porra a galera tá ou, eu estou muito louco.
Ou a galera no brasil aqui não está acompanhando.
O cenário o novo cenário né da da incorporação da ia ali dentro das empresas eu até comentei isso aqui também mas, ainda bem que está começando a mudar e realmente está e está sendo rápido eu achei que fosse mais lento mas está sendo rápido.
E essa semana quando eu comecei a, falar do que eu aprendi do meu conhecimento fiz desafios e tal cara o rosto da galera era, um sorrisão assim sabe e hoje eu senti muito isso.
Quando o cara, disse para mim cara o cara chega e falou assim cara tá fechado foi assim ele chega fechou ele fez assim ó.
Está fechado cara. Eu fiquei muito feliz, e é isso aqui cara essa primeira nossa, iniciativa de procurar, o conhecimento.
E o conhecimento em lugares certos assim sabe.
Claro, claro. é isso.
E você cara você é é uma, inspiração se tornou meu mentor.
Te vejo no Datasip, filho.
Né e assim cara só quero, lhe agradecer e dar esse, testemunho aqui, a todo mundo aqui.
Estarei lá.
Estarei lá com certeza.
Não, Datasip, dois mil e vinte e sete. Vejo lá esteja que é do cara. Não é por nada. Não, Mas é Do Caralho Se Você Puder Participar é Do Caralho Valeu.
Tamo junto! Gente.
Vou participar sim, antes de você falar eu, já ia falar eu já ia para lá.
Obrigado, thiago.
Valeu, galera valeu boa viagem aí luan.
Nada. Tamo junto. Obrigado.
O Thiago também sempre está comigo. Já faz muitos anos.
Estou fazendo a formação em dia. Interesse em datasip também. Mas pareceu algo mais avançado que chama modelo. Carreira. Faz Sentido Datasip Para Alguém Mais No Começo.
Caio, Datasip, eu não estou preocupado. Em qual nível você está? Eu estou preocupado na sua mentalidade.
Porque não? é um programa de.
Não um programa de dinheiro. Ele é caro.
Ele é muito caro. Ele é um programa já caro, mas não é o dinheiro. Eu vou revisar e eu Vou Ver Se Faz Sentido Você Entrar Ou Não.
Então, assim é o Mindset.
A questão. Mindset sempre é sobre o Mindset.
Só que agora, com a Ia cada vez mais ainda fica mais exorbitante. Ficaram mais de sete, certo? Leva você Muito Mais Que Você Tem Uma Frota De Agentes E Frameworks E Processos.
E asa para poder construir o que você não conseguia fazer antes. E olhar ainda para o cliente.
Agora a gente consegue olhar para o cliente e consegue fazer tudo ao mesmo tempo. Então, assim.
é só isso. Tá.
Beleza e gente agradecer. Eu vou sair agora, já que ninguém tem mais nada para fazer, porque eu tenho que Estar Onze Horas No Aeroporto.
Foi um prazer. Espero que vocês tenham gostado. Acompanhe meu Instagram.
Que eu vou postar algumas coisas legais que eu falei aqui, que eu quero falar no Instagram para todo mundo.
Acompanhe as coisas que a gente vai ter. Quem é da comunidade? Quem ainda não adquiriu a formação que vale a pena adquira.
Porque vão ter a comunidade. Permaneça quem tiver interesse, fala com a mãe.
Deixa fazer um grande movimento. Agora, nos próximos dois meses na comunidade, e você vai querer estar ali.
Com atualização. Eu vou trazer outros instrutores também de fora, inclusive para poder fazer algumas coisas. Então.
Eu não parei. Não tá? Então, muito pelo contrário. A gente tá só começando. Beleza.
As para que vocês tenham curtido. Desculpa minha voz. A gente teve uns Bumps durante o caminho, mas deu tudo certo.
Afinal entregue, tá? Eu tô cozinhando as tarefas aqui. Pra quem entra lá no entra lá no Boot Camp. Todo mundo.
Que puder, inclusive depois. Adilson, manda esse link aí.
Para o meu time, para a Cristina ou para a Mayara.
Para eles colocarem como grupo de entrar para a galera que assistiu o botecamp gravado entrar e também poder interagir, Poder Ter A Mesma Coisa.
Porque eu vou postar todas essas informações aqui.
Lá antes da gente fechar tudo. Porque eu quero ter certeza que vocês viram.
Todo o processo completo que está batendo aqui. Cem beleza.
Obrigado, todo mundo aí, agradeço. Ficou até o final.
Beijo no coração de vocês. Bom final de semana. Descansem.
Foi uma semana cansativa. Relaxa agora.
Só tenta dar um tempo na cabeça. Pega isso depois. Espera as coisas comitarem. Descansa.
E a gente se vê no próximo treinamento.
Beleza falou. Galera.